afternoon
just a reminder that meeting will be
live streamed and the recording of it
will be placed on the council's website
item one of today's agenda is apologies
for absence
yes thank you chair we have apologies
today from councillor cooper who's
substituted by councillor fernell and
councillor ridgway has also sent her
apologies
thank you are there any other
i think we're all here now
item two declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest and or other interest
not already on their register of
interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
have we received any declarations in
advance
[Music]
thank you are there any
members wishing to declare this
afternoon
no thank you
item three minutes of the last meeting
we have now the minutes of our meeting
held on tuesday the 19th of october
are we happy that these are our correct
record
thank you we do have before i should
have jumped the gun a bit there um just
a few words from adrian regarding the
106 monies that were raised at our last
meeting
just in relation to the
details on page 9 of the papers members
will recall the discussion about section
106 agreements back in october and
questions in particular from councillors
foster and liggett and just further to
those uh chair i've written to
council
in relation to the wall pack that she
raised with officers and
as we discussed with committee last time
chair the issues that council foster
discussed with us and we will bring that
in the update that will come back to
members in a couple of months time has
agreed
thank you chair
thank you are we all happy with those
thank you if uh i'd take it was
councillor elliot moved them
and second by councillor armitage all
those in favor can have a show of hands
please
thank you
those against
any abstentions none the motion was
carried
the main business of this afternoon and
we have two applications to consider as
well as the appeals report
as you can see each of the items has its
own report and i am happy with this and
intend to consider
this is the business in order
before we do i would like the client to
explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on youtube
how we will deal with these applications
[Music]
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
applications at the meeting
we will consider the two applications in
the order they are set out on the agenda
the chair will introduce the application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late iceland's agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
after this the chair will ask each of
the speakers
objectors then the applicants or their
agent
to speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
the reminder given by the clock when 30
seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes
members of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary
to clarify any points they have made
when we have heard from all of the
speakers on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
and look for the speakers
once the application you've come to
speak on has been dealt with
you may leave the chamber or the zoom
platform
if you choose to remain
then please note you will not be allowed
to participate further in the meeting
from that point
as you are aware this meeting is being
live streamed and recording will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
recall and record and copy this
recording from the internet
thank you chair
thank you
the first application which is for
homewood which is ned forward slash 2100
853 forward slash fl
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning manager and
officers to tell us about any late
comment reports that have been produced
and to give a brief presentation showing
any photos and plans of the site
i will allow the officers to complete
their presentation
consequently members should please
reserve any points of order or questions
about the process until the end
there'll be plenty of time for questions
later
adrian are you taking this or is it
graham it'll be myself thank you graeme
can somebody just enable screen sharing
so i can share the presentation
we have a an exploration as part of the
technical design whether there is any
potential for soakaway testing
in terms of the fact that whether or not
the water any surface water can run off
into the existing kind of ground
conditions again at a slower rate but at
the moment the preliminary investigation
is suggesting that's not necessarily
possible uh based on the kind of
existing ground conditions but it is yet
to be fully determined
and as you may be aware there are a
number of different steps that's taken
in order to try and maximize the um the
application of the
systems to avoid kind of connections
into public sewers wherever possible
however ultimately if there is no other
solution available then that becomes an
option that is available but it has to
be have gone through a sequential test
to ensure that that is
that those other options have been
applied prior to simply just making a
connection
so that is still to be determined
subject to the detail kind of uh design
that would kind of subsequently follow
on post approval
so you're expecting us to make a
decision when you really come up with an
uh satisfactory answer
would it be right i think i don't think
that's necessarily the case this has
been through the local lead flood
authority and we had a kind of dialogue
backwards and forwards with regard to
the kind of proposals that have been put
forward there have been a number of
adaptations that have been made by the
drenching
engineer in order to respond to the
concerns they have come back with a
number of conditions that are to be
applied to any approval which are then
acting as a safeguard in terms of
ensuring that the design is suitable and
appropriate for the location in question
so
i think in terms of whilst there are
elements that are still to be defined
and determined as there are with the
external building design as there are
with any application that is being
approved or determined up and down the
country there are certain elements that
still need to be looked at kind of post
approval and hence they the discussions
with the statutory council teams have
produced no objections in principle to
the scheme however where there are
elements that still need to be worked
upon or developed they have applied
appropriate conditions to safeguard that
work and gives the opportunity for the
council to reject or
amend or
approve at a later date i think that's a
fair and reasonable approach
so counselor on the teacher you've had
quite a stab at this if we move on to
council foster
thank you chair uh good afternoon mr
woods uh my question is around the the
106 one is
when we look in our pike uh on page 38
8.3 it states financial contributions
were requested in relation to the
education uh so dcc have 188 000 and
we've also got uh play space
enhancements
uh along with the maintenance
contributions so we've got but we're
upwards of two hundred thousand uh
however it was concluded that the scheme
wasn't viable which is understandable
when you're asking for uh that sort of
money and so what you're looking for is
permission
for these uh for a hundred percent
scheme of
affordable
housing
but giving new 106 monies so my concern
i just welcome your comments around this
uh it's it's you've concluded i'm
guessing it's not just our offices but
i'm guessing uh
agents and builders have concluded that
the 188 188 000
would not be financially viable but i
understand but it's a kind of all or
nothing
uh
now it's it's understandable that you
wish to uh build these properties and
give no one or six monies that is
understandable from the developers uh uh
point of view i've got no difficulty
with that however
um there's got to be i think there must
be some there there must be some uh
some space in the middle it's obviously
uh you can't give 188
000 on that many properties when they're
all affordable so it's kind of a uh on
or off there i just wonder if you've got
any comments at all with regards to what
would be uh viable yet still giving one
or six monies
i think i think what one of the one of
the kind of points that have been made
and we've discussed with with officers
during the determination period is
obviously what we if we're looking at
this from a private developer point of
view and the fact that you're looking at
somebody that is going to be generating
units that are going to be built for
profit and sale and therefore generating
should we say a financial return out of
the development side then
as architects designers we are fully in
support of the section 106 scheme in
terms of being able to kind of give back
to the community in which the the kind
of development will be effectively
benefiting from in this instance we are
doing an entirely affordable scheme here
which basically means that the scheme
inherently is not being built for profit
it's being built for the benefit of the
local community and essentially giving
something back so by virtue of the fact
of its designation as affordable housing
in essence it is in in line with the
principles of the section 106 funding in
terms of what that's trying to do what
we are doing at the moment i i'm not
partying to the full kind of financial
viability details associated with the
application i simply an architect and
draw pictures is generally how i kind of
simplify my job title
it is
it is something where
as a construction of of these units
there are it is going to be financially
kind of in the balance in terms of kind
of it's not something this is going to
be generating a profit
emh oversight it is massive they already
have in their kind of effectively their
portfolio
it makes sense for them to be able to
kind of generate the affordable housing
the product they deliver and build up
and down the kind of the east midlands
um based on the fact that they already
own the site what it doesn't mean is the
fact that they are going to be making
any significant kind of funds out of
this say ultimately this is an
affordable housing scheme that will be
providing much needed affordable housing
for people in the local community and
that's what's at the forefront of the
development not about making money and
not about making profit
equally when you balance it with this
there is not necessarily
any sums of money that then can be kind
of given to to other causes in order to
kind of facilitate kind of development
elsewhere this is this is kind of on the
margins and that's what essentially what
the viability assessment has sort of
deduced and has been agreed through
with uh northeast obviously district
council as well
thank you for that thank you
councillor
[ __ ] good afternoon um
i think a lot of my questions have
actually been asked the the same as
council of foster and councillor
armitage but to this um attenuation
water
is that being slowly released into the
150 mil server that's running under the
houses no no this this would all be
subject this would all be basically into
saying that the foul war the 150 mil
that is existingly
existing on site and runs in the
underneath the proposed building is a
foul water service so we wouldn't be
connecting to that
um essentially any new drainage
infrastructure that goes in with the
site would basically be formed out of
kind of new drainage connections etc
prior to connecting into into the main
sewers or effectively just off off-site
um so yeah there would be no
at the moment there's not necessarily
any intentions to be sort of forging
kind of major connection to existing
kind of under undersized pipes et cetera
it's all subject to a detailed modeling
analysis um prior to it then forging
connections into existing series
elsewhere
and also regarding the going backwards
quite a way but uh regarding the houses
standing at the moment would it not be
possible or on about you know bringing
it up to modern standards would it not
be possible to have the external
cladding which has been put on an awful
lot of properties at the moment
in in essence yes uh i can't argue that
you couldn't necessarily do that however
i think all of the arguments have been
made about the
kind of
the old natural retention of ellen house
is the fact that it's it's beautiful on
the outside all the comments have been
made that it's beautiful on the outside
if you're then looking at applying a
modern insulated render system on the
outside then inherently you are then
destroying what was the original feature
that people are kind of wishing to
seek and retain um
it's
it's not a it's not a it's still equally
not going to go back to my previous
comments there are measures that could
be placed on twitter house in order to
improve the thermal efficiency and that
would improve the building but it still
wouldn't be up to the standards that
we'd be able to generate out of a kind
of a new build construction and equally
it would be commercially and financially
far more unviable to do so
do you intend reusing the bricks of that
house or are we
crushing those up and bringing new
bricks in
at this stage
again that decision has not necessarily
been kind of confirmed but they would be
but by virtue of the age there will be
imperial bricks as opposed to metric
bricks therefore they wouldn't
necessarily coordinate with the same
kind of building kind of standards that
we're working on or assuming for the new
modern build development what we've
often done on sites where we've had
existing structures on site is the fact
that when the building has been
demolished instead of materials being
kind of taken off site they are crushed
on site and potentially can be offered
up for creating the kind of hardcore and
sub basis so essentially you're having a
lower carbon footprint as a result of
that kind of demolition process and
keeping material on site
as opposed to demolishing exporting from
site and then importing fresh material
alongside to form sub bases etc so i
think in the climate in which we're
working at the moment that is something
that could be kind of considered
thank you
are there any further questions
council arsenal
okay well
i'm interested that you're doing this
for the benefit of the community and
you're not making any profits so you
can't pay a 106. so i think
you're the first contractor a builder
they've come across that's not making
profit out of some development so i'll
congratulate you for that my question
really relates to traffic and parking
you did say you provided adequate
parking arrangements for
the residents and for visitors but could
you explain how that will work on the
site
uh yeah i mean essentially we have a
level of parking um that is providing
200 parking for all of the houses which
is a minimum of two spaces per dwelling
with the apartments there are um
one space per apartment with two for one
of the two bed apartments and then we
have a visitor space for the apartments
and a couple of visitor spaces on
the tip shop road access as well
um i think there's adequate space within
the site to accommodate the the
vehicle movements that we're likely to
anticipate and in terms of going back to
the points about highway safety or
transport safety
the uh one of the things to bear in mind
is the existing usage is on site at the
moment will be it's a redundant entity
but the permission is in place for
office accommodation and the former kind
of public house uses
would be able to cater for or generate a
much higher number of vehicles using
that heathrow point of access than would
currently be generated by or would be
generated by the proposed development so
therefore the number of vehicle
movements have the heathrow access would
actually be kind of minimized over the
lifetime of the development and
hopefully will be spread out over the
course of a working day as opposed to
being a more focused kind of access and
egress point at kind of rush hour
periods or at kind of localized points
throughout the day
you you said one
parking spot for one bedroom apartments
and two slots for two bedroom
yeah
i'm not sure how many two-bedroom
apartments there are under development
is there any one
just one and two visitor slots did you
say
one visitors lot
there's one parking for vision in the
apartment and two on the tip shelf road
access
right and would each of these slots be
allocated to specific apartments yes
i think you can have a problem
i don't think enough parking
that's that's a that's a point of
opinion um based on the design has been
designed in accordance with the dollar
ship highway standards it's been sent
out
twice as part of the the application
process once on the initial scheme when
we have 20 units and then once again
when the scheme has been reduced down to
19 units there's been no adverse
comments in relation to the parking
provision that's been met
okay
thank you
thank you are there any further
questions
councillor jones
yeah just looking at the
what we have um a diagram of the actual
site
what at least i can't read them because
it's so small but on the right hand side
on each road
there's
like quite a space with an outline of a
building in it but that comes
outside of the red line i think
very difficult to tell
doing nothing about that piece of land
there
what is that building it's off eighth
road
is that the problem i can't read it
because it's a little tiny tiny writing
yeah i believe i believe you might be
referring to number 77 heath road is
that 77
right i think so
yeah i mean there's all that
parking at the moment that big
expanse of concrete well or whatever it
is
um
a lot of these will go on to that won't
they the new apartments will go into
that area where the concrete is
i think
a huge amount of decides in terms of the
external the external kind of ground is
made up of hard standing which you say
is currently just a kind of sea of
tarmac um which obviously facilitated
the car parking facilities for the
former use as offices and both as a
public house as well
um consequently that doesn't have a huge
benefit to the site in terms of any kind
of surface water drainage and runoff on
the basis it's a kind of an impermeable
layer
hopefully what can be seen as a result
of the proposals put forward is that
there is a huge amount of more green
space associated to this development and
therefore creates a much larger volume
of impervious area as opposed to
impermeable area and hence could be of
benefit to the the kind of the natural
drainage of site anyway
and i just tried to understand it as
well so the actual house that would come
down
is mainly parking areas on this isn't it
uh yeah and also
partially occupied by plot seven
thank you
that's really it
yeah mr woods
is anyone ever a able to buy these
houses out outright or do do they just
maintain a 40 stake
it
it would it would by definition of the
fact it's an affordable housing scheme
um it is effectively would need to
remain that in perpetuity so whilst i
think jay mentioned about the fact that
people can buy on the shared ownership
properties can buy
a stake in that property they will never
be able to and they might be able to
increase that state proportionally over
their lifetime in order to kind of
increase their should we say level of
ownership
there will never be an ability for
anybody to purchase these outright and
therefore essentially become a market
sale property in the future
um that's what's kind of the shared
ownership sort of scheme does it it kind
of limits and prevents that
um and
they can essentially kind of sort of
maintain those to say affordable housing
right away through
you see i get that what you're saying
about the shared ownership properties
but for me an affordable house is
something someone can buy own and
probably want to stay in for the rest of
their lives but own outright
that for me is
buying an affordable house
okay i might i might have to might have
to defer back to jane on on that if
that's okay
you see
and it might be ticking boxes and
getting around being able to call it
affordable housing but for me affordable
housing and maybe this is just my take
on it is a house that you can buy
over a certain amount of time just like
you get a mortgage for a house but
eventually it's yours not just 40
ownership because at some point who
or if they ever decided to sell them who
decrees how much the extra 60 is worth
at some point and does that then become
not affordable
if you know what i'm saying because i'm
i'm still stuck with the section 106
where you know i read in other reports
is there because
um
it's again it says about the as we've
heard from the objectives it says about
the contribution towards education
health and place space
and and as such the officers in
agreement with the planning manager
consider it should be determined by us
by the members and the planning
committee in line with our constitution
so i don't see and i don't want this to
be a complete not a stumbling block
because in my mind so far they can
neither afford them out right never buy
them out right and you guys don't want
to put anything in towards the local
community that's how i see it
might be a quite a narrow view of it
you know but that's how i see it
i'm i'm
being told that there is there is the
flexibility that the the kind of the
share or the ownerships of the shares
can be kind of staircased upwards to a
maximum of 100
um so ultimately then that would that
would kind of reach that kind of goal
that you're talking about however
it is subject in terms of the kind of
the cost of those states it's all
subject to rics valuations in order to
kind of assess the the affordability and
the price that is governed by those
particular shares etc
i'm going to have to
essentially probably stop there because
it is going beyond our level of kind of
knowledge and i think if if we want to
kind of have a kind of more detailed
discussion it's either something that
would probably need to be dealt with by
the applicant themselves uh or it's a
kind of a subsequent decision i think
i understand that thanks very much for
your help on it anyway okay thank you
any further questions before we move on
no thank you thank you very much thank
you
okay the next part is offices to
questions and no doubt there'll be quite
a few of those
i'll start the list now
are there any questions for officers
counselor hall councillor hancock
we're going to get the video that's
wrong
[Music]
are we going to get the video up of the
officers yeah as soon as um as soon as
they start to respond their face will
only be on your screen okay right thank
you uh just i just wanted to know what
weight do we have to put on the
uh ellen well the old ellen house as it
is at the moment is there much weight we
have to
put on that regarding this planet
application please
just come back on that first chain then
graham will oh i don't think he things
approach i'm sure
the the weight to be attached to any
element chair is a matter for the
decision maker and that's the planning
committee in this instance
in terms of
heritage and non-heritage
assets sorry non-designated heritage
assets heritage assets are those that
are listed
or conservation areas so they are
designated nationally in this instance
neither of those apply to this
application
in terms of non-designated heritage
assets the council itself doesn't have a
local list of those properties
however we rely on the historic
environment record which is referred to
in the mppf
and if a structural building or other
feature is identified on that
list the historic environment record and
we classify that in our consideration as
a non-designated heritage asset in this
instance chair ellen house isn't a
non-designated energy asset by that
definition
and therefore chair from an officer
point of view
taken the application on its face and
it's the demolition of a non-designated
building
and therefore you've placed a
minimal weight on that issue
rather attaching great weight to the
delivery of 100 affordable housing on
this site
and as you may have heard and you may
wish to discuss with us chair we've set
that um indeed in a greater weight than
this instance the delivery of any
section 106 contributions in view of the
viability assessment that's been
undertaken i hope that helps council
hall chair
thank you
councillor ann cogg
thank you chair um actually just picking
up on on a couple of points is
referenced a few times in the report
um
i'll point us to 7.46 but it does recur
throughout there are references to
overlooking and particularly
7.48
we've got in officer's opinion present
prevent any harmful overlooking how are
you defining harmful overlooking given
that we've
declined extensions in the past purely
because a guest bedroom window has
overlooked someone else's garden um this
this to me
isn't really appropriate on the
neighbors so i'm wanting a bit of
clarification as to how you're defining
this
and how big a weight
we need to place on it when uh when we
make a decision
again chair as i just mentioned the
weight to be attached to any particular
issue is is that for the decision-making
mission since that's the the planning
committee from an officer point of view
we've set out in the report
the various distances and to and
out with the properties both within and
outside the the application site and
we've taken into account the distances
that are set out between the scheme and
the existing properties but also the
existing situation particularly in
respect of the muse building and you'll
have seen earlier when graham identified
muse in particular
there are rear-facing windows from that
property already and hence our
conclusion that based on the existing
situation
and the
potential for
overlooking of neighbouring properties
and the design of the existing scheme
and the distances to those properties
and gardens
but the impact of the scheme is
acceptable weighing all those things in
the balance
chair the issue of overlooking is is one
for
for members as i've said but in the
opinion officers the scheme will provide
no greater impact on neighbours for
those reasons than the existing
situation hence our conclusion on that
issue
i i'd just like to clarify jeff i can
because obviously bear in mind we're
totally changing usage here so any
overlooking that we have currently is
purely during working hours
um any overlooking that we would have
from domestic residences would be 24
hours a day
so i i i'm again i'm wanting really a
little bit more clarification on your
usage of this adjective which officers
have put in not me of it not being
harmful
[Music]
i can add a little to what i've already
said sharon that the existing situation
is
is as is there is a proximity of
windows to boundaries
that may be during only during the day
maybe at other times i'm not aware
there's any restriction on the
times of
day that the existing properties can be
occupied or used not aware of anything
in the roadshare
and on the basis of that and the
distances that are set out in the report
as officers we believe that the scheme
has proposed will not be any more
detrimental to neighbours than the
existing situation
thank you councillor armitage
thank you
the uh
106 agreement
uh
as i understand it because they are
uh affordables as such
uh there's no 106
agreement monies to be paid
but then
it goes on uh the agent
of the architect to say that these
houses
uh
could be uh
at a later stage on a step thing
well surely then
they uh
it's applicable that the 106 payment
should be made
the 106 would only be
delivered on the back of the
planning consent
and therefore if
as you've heard mr woods explain
properties or owners of those properties
staircased out of
a rental element of the ownership of the
house that there would be no subsequent
requirement on them those occupiers then
to pay any 106 contributions in this
instance chair the the 106 contributions
have been asked originally by the
various bodies
particularly in the case of the
occasionality when they understood
viability assessment had been done and
it had delivered an outcome that one
over six contributions couldn't be
achieved
the
county council as educational authority
accepted that on its face and noted that
with the delivery of the 100 affordable
housing
that the it was unrealistic to require
that and hence their comments on it
in this instance as officers we placed
great weight on the delivery of that 10
affordable housing and the
delivery of that is protected by the
condition six that's recommended
and that would ensure that the houses
are delivered
as far as
can be required in perpetuity to that
purpose hence our conclusion that view
of the viability assessment undertaken
and particularly the circumstances
of the proposal i.e 100 affordable
housing that in this instance that
outweighs any
other requirement that there may
otherwise be to section 106 requirements
notwithstanding the fact that the scheme
in its form is
deemed not viable not only by sales
chair but by independent assessors
thank you
thank you council foster
okay uh mr kirkham uh i'm looking at uh
and i didn't see this early so my
apologies that page 26 7.17 an
independent assessment undertaken on
behalf of the council confirms that the
scheme is shown to be unviable even
before the one of six contributions are
factored in could you tell me a little
bit more about that uh independent
assessment showing that it's unviable
please
again chair if i can start if i get this
incorrect and graham i'm sure i'll
correct me what's the the process we
follow the chair is that
where
a scheme is
deemed on the bible taking into account
section 106 contributions of those
requested
we seek
through the cooperation with the
applicant's foot appointed by
ourselves as the council an independent
assessment of that so we're not just
taking the viability assessment of the
applicants on his face without question
we get
that
reassessed
independently by council appointed
surveyors and in this instance
that appointment and those appointed
surveyors have deemed the guests on the
basis of all their knowledge all their
understanding their experience and
the phones we use are experienced in
this area they have concluded that yes
the scheme is not viable
to deliver section 106 contributions in
this case because of all the elements
that go into that and in particular as i
say in this case the
delivery of 100 affordable housing
thank you for that hope that helps
against the foster chair
thank you are there any further
questions
no thank you councillor
and thank you officers
i don't know if graham wants to come in
and add anything to that
i think it aided he's covered everything
there
okay thank you
okay we can move on to uh the sessions
regarding debate
and i thank the officers for their
information this leads us to the final
part of our process
but before going any further i would
just like to ask the clerk to remind us
about motions
yes thank you chair
please bear in mind members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then the amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendation
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues and be supported by the evidence
as necessary
if a motion to reject offer officer
recommendations false
or in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision
through a further motion in favor of the
recommendations
or another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another
vote in terms of the timings of the
motions these should be moved and
seconded after the committee has heard
read and discussed the evidence before
it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached
and will then invite motions to be put
when members will be reminded of this by
the clerk
if they wish to propose a motion before
then
thank you chair
thank you thank you
the floor is open
councillor liggett then councillor hall
i was just going to agree with
councillor elliot actually this
so-called affordable housing
i find it very hard to get my head
around um and i don't really see how it
helps people on the property ladder
because when it comes to selling
um they value
the house again and i know what's
happening around laws they're
inflated valuations
um but also it makes it very difficult
for us when they can't give us any
indication of
the market value that they're going to
put these properties on
councillor hall
yeah thank you just a few points i've
listened to what people have said about
section 1061a
about
the building i do like to see old
buildings saved i'm not one for
wanting to see them demolished
also when it comes to affordable housing
again what is affordable to one person
may not be affordable to another um but
we can see from the
plans that the one two three bedrooms
it's not like they're all six-bedroom
detached properties so
under under the scheme of things and
bearing in mind that property has been
vacant for a few years
what
i'd like to suggest that we follow go
with officer's recommendations please
are there any
other comments i'm so foster there chad
i've got council of foster then
councillor hancock
uh thank you chair uh when it comes to
this definition i think we've got to uh
trust that we've been given the correct
information that these are
uh 100 affordable houses
and it's not just for sale it's also
for rental as well
so they do we do know they meet that
definition that's the first thing
uh second one is
uh when we look through this um
and i've referred to this
in other planning meetings
you know there's
there's nothing on here as regards
policy why
this cannot
be refused this information there's
nothing on policy at all all the way
through this we've got no policies
quoted at all uh i understand the
feelings
and i understand the concerns
but
a lot of that is very subjective we've
got nothing uh
on policy here
um
so
nothing at all and lastly i've got some
concerns around uh the ward member who
this is i don't know but the ward
members comments
i've got some concern around that as
well that these have been included in
here like that took him out unscrupulous
developers i think that's an absolute
nonsense and those comments shouldn't be
allowed in
on that and uh i noticed when it comes
to the 4.3 counter county council of
wale jack wally's wooly's name has been
mentioned there
whoever whoever the ward member is their
name will also wants to go on there next
time when they make comments like this
because those comments aren't
appropriate as i'm concerned
uh if they've got objections they should
be citing you know wider objection and
doing it correctly you know we've all
had the training
uh so going back to it i can't see
anything that uh i know this is not the
place in the meeting where we do put any
proposals forward i can't see anything
here that uh
any reason to expose this thank you
chair thank you council hancock
thank you chair um i mean just typical
actually this is what i was going to
raise but just pick one mark's point
there
gs5 does bother me in terms of the
overlooking so there is there is a
potential policy policy one there
depending obviously as to whether
members think is sufficient
um i'll be honest the scheme concerns me
i think yes ideally i would like them to
adapt the building we've already got i
think that would be preferable
um whether it's it's viable or not i'm
i'm uncertain i'm unclear
i think um
the key thing with regard to section 106
which i have a huge problem with here
is is the fact ultimately section 106 is
designed to mitigate the impact of
development on on the surrounding area
and that's the key point is mitigation
and i think
the the the problem that we have here
any development will always have an
impact even if it's just on nhs use the
fact that we've also got some
three-bedroom properties here
indicates that there is going to be an
impact on schooling and such like so the
fact that we're getting nothing from
that
is is a concern i i think it would be
more viable if we were to be looking at
a one-bedroom affordable rental flat
rented flats
without necessarily a 106 contribution
because they would have less of an
impact on the
on the surrounding area and i think
council finale made a very good point
yes it may fit calculations but you're
not telling me if there's anywhere near
enough parking spaces for that it's like
one person out of all those flats can
have a visitor at any one time it's it's
ludicrous isn't it so
i i've got huge concerns
again it's it's not the point but i i've
been inclined to bounce it back for an
alternative proposal cost to me yes we
need the affordable housing but i don't
think this is the right proposal
i just comment on that uh gs5 yeah i can
see where you're coming from but there's
so much weight on that and i don't
believe it's enough enough when it comes
to that
and and when it comes to it um
we've got to give
you know
an opinion on this it's given to us this
development as it's put in front of us
we don't say we'd rather you bring
another development to us we have to
give an opinion on this one we don't say
we don't see this existing house used
it's that's not our job here is to look
at this application as it stands
um
absolutely but we can recommend back
that it's deferred an alternative put to
us we've done that before it can be done
you've got to find sorry sorry through
the chair you've got to find grounds to
be able to do that
i can't see grounds here okay counselor
pal
uh thank you chair um
they do say that beauty is in the eye of
the beholder
if someone says to me um
think of a beautiful historic building
i think ellen house would come very low
on my list i see no heritage value in it
whatsoever
and so i think that's a complete red
herring
um
we know that in that area there is a
need for affordable housing
um
and i think this is an opportunity that
that should be seized
um
if we were to demand a 106 well the
scheme would fail no houses would be
built
and therefore no people will be able to
move into them
i don't find parking loodycross as
council honda [ __ ] says and i use his
word
um
so i um i can i can see no planning
reasons why we should not
do other than support it
thank you thank you is that the end of
the debate
well i'm going to put my head about the
parapet then and put the motion in i do
share a lot of your concerns and
it's quite an emotive subject 106 monies
but i will support the officer's
recommendations and i hope this
and council armitage's second it will
take a one call nikki
thank you chair if members could clearly
state fought against or abstain
counselor armitage
counselor elliott
councillor foster
for
casa for now
castle hall
how's the hancock
against
how's the hearts on
for
cancer jones
for
councillor liggett
castle powell for
that's 11 votes four one against zero
abstentions it's carried chair thank you
very much thank you members and a lot
lot longer than i anticipated but there
we go thank you very much if you wish to
leave please feel free to do so
and the next application we have is at
westington and that is for ned forward
slash
zero one zero zero five
forward slash fl
apologies i'll i'll take this uh item so
thanks share
thank you
so we've had no late reps
for this application so i've got nothing
to report on on that front
the reasons for this application being
before members today is that council
lewis is a serving member
and in line with the council's
constitution should be considered by
planning committee
the proposal is for a timber-framed
gazebo positioned on site views in
conjunction with the winery business
officers conclude that the proposed
structure would be of an appropriate
design which would be sympathetic to and
not cause harm to the distinctive
landscape character in this location
as a result is
officers consider that the scheme should
be supported in line with the
recommendation
so i'll just go through the i've only
got a few slides here for you so
as it states the reference is twenty one
four zero one double o five four slash
fl construction of an open-sided timber
gazebo
measuring six meters long by four meters
wide by three and a half meters high at
amber valley winds
that's a backlight back lane at
westington
so this orange area donates the site so
this is just to the east of westington
so just off back lane
so as you can see on site there is an
act centralized access onto back lane
you've got a little stable building
on the southern portion of the site
you've got some vines that have been
planted up here
you've got an orchard area here
so the next slide will show
the position so hopefully that's that
still makes sense so you've got back
lane running along here you've got
access into the site roughly here the
vineyard up here and an orchard here so
the blue outline just proposes where the
gazebo will be on site
so it's just a bit more zoomed in
version so hopefully that's clear enough
pretty self-explanatory
so these are a few elevation plans of
the of the timber gazebo so it's going
to be timber framed with a with a slate
roof with a hip design
it's very open sided
that's just a side elevation
this is a view taken from the site
entrance looking
east across the site so as you can see
the land levels kind of slope down
you've got views through
the vines here and in just in the
background there you can make out the
orchard
so it's roughly where the gazebo will
will go
that ends the presentation for that one
nice and straightforward
thank you
as with no speakers are there any
questions for graham
no
thank you well in which case
is there any need for a debate
thank
you and roll call
thank you chair for members could
clearly state fought against her abstain
councillor armitage for
cancer elliott
councillor foster
councillor for now
councillor hall
councillor hancock four council hearts
one
councillor jones
councillor liggett
councillor powell
councillor rouse four casa rough four
that's 12 plus four zero against your
extensions it's carriage sure thank you
very much
uh item seven planning appeals lodged
and determined
is there anything on that
adrian any questions for adrian on that
apologies
there's nothing on there and then you'll
see that we only have the one appeal and
determined over the past four weeks turn
that set out of paragraph 1.2
thank you
thank you
is that okay
okay
uh item eight matters of urgency now i
haven't any matters of urgency but what
i would like to bring to members
is members training we've had a
couple of inquiries for members training
one is for
basic refresher members training
and i'm quite in favor of this but i'd
also like um
input from the actual officers so we can
understand from the ground up i've
listened
over the year to some of the comments
that have been made and i think there's
still some lack of understanding on some
of us about the the work and how it all
starts so
i'm quite happy for that one and i've
also had one request for training
regarding trees our favorite subject
but if anyone else has got any items
that they would like raised or concerned
about
if you'd like to contact mark as the
members training officer or myself
i don't know if mark's got anything
to say add
thank you chad yeah i think you've
caught it well that's the ones we've had
put forward so far the two elements one
was training on trees for planning
members uh so we didn't get as ashes
mixed up from our beaches
and the rest uh the other one was the
basics again uh going going through the
process from what happens when an
application uh
planning application comes into the
uh the council and how it reaches its
end process so um
that's what we had put forward so i'd
welcome any other uh contributions from
uh members here
uh as to what training they might want
this will be put forward to member
development and we'll be discussing it
there
uh it's already gone from member
development to the uh
to the individual uh
political groups but uh while we're here
i asked the chair to mention it to
members present
thank you so it's on the table if you'd
like to take the offer up thank you very
much
councillor pam
um i think one of the things that's been
demonstrated this afternoon is that we
did it sometimes difficult to know what
an actual definition is from a from a
word or a phrase
like affordable housing it isn't just a
oh it's something you can afford there
is a formula
and a definition about what an
affordable house is
so i think if we took a number of things
even as simple as that
to have a
a definition of what it is so that when
we are here
when somebody says affordable housing we
know what's behind it
thank you chad
thank you and thank you all very much
members and safe journey home
you